so there used to be this thing called a
party the concept was simple
gather a bunch of living breathing
bodies in the same place
at the same time and just see what
happens
some parties were promises and those
were called weddings and other parties
were goodbyes and those were called
funerals there were parties to warm new
homes and parties to mark the day you
were born
and parties to signal the arrival of a
new year
and if my friends wanted me to be on
time to a party they'd lie
i wasn't proud of my reputation with
time but
do you think my lateness is genetic i
don't know
no yeah because it's too much like your
dads like there's a lot of different
ways to be late
but you're late in this particular way
that's exactly like him
have you ever heard of ist yeah indian
standard time
uh it means it means
that you don't have a sense of time
once someone was describing their color
blindness to me and it reminded me a lot
of how i feel about time
how i know that 3pm and 305 are
technically different
but i personally don't perceive that
contrast time resembles color in other
ways too
we can only access the smallest sliver
of both spectrums
non-linearity and relativity remind me
of ultraviolet and red green
what scientists call the impossible
colors colors we can measure
but can't actually see in light color
time is continuous we can't locate the
seam of an hour
the border of a day the same way we
can't declare with any precision
where yellow becomes orange or orange
becomes red
and yet over the course of human
evolution we've insatiably sought to
structure time
dividing the sun into angles and tidally
organizing the story of our lives into
years
it kind of embarrassed me humans taking
the unfathomable expanse of time and
refining it into hours
the universe is 13.8 billion years old
who our weed is assert the importance of
a minute
but i tried my best to banish those
thoughts i bought clocks and set them to
five minutes early
i filled calendars with meticulous
month-long plans
i even put a white board on my fridge
and every morning i wrote the date down
i was finally closing the gap becoming
one of those people who holds the reins
of time
and then the pandemic happened and
suddenly tuesdays were thursdays were
sundays
flowers bloomed and wilted and babies
learned to crawl
and gray hairs grew in but the larger
story of time felt interrupted
bland birthdays and cancelled weddings
and solitary holidays
doing the same thing in the same place
from the same people day after day
after day previously imperceptible
shades of time
showed up at our doorsteps like special
relativity
in the spring time moved glacially as it
does alongside black holes
and then without warning it accelerated
so that when i asked my mom what day in
may we were on
she gently informed me it was july more
non-linearity
and we emerged after months spent holed
up in our homes only to find ourselves
reliving the very same moment that had
driven us
inside in the first place the whole
world joined me in temporal
disorientation
even my punctual superiors were at a
loss they knew how to arrive five
minutes early
not how to repeat the same five minutes
43 854
times i regretted taking time for
granted
now i would give anything to hear
someone say the party starts at five or
the doors close at eight
don't be late
it turns out our perception of time is
incredibly malleable
even color can distort it when people
are shown blue and red stimuli of the
same duration
they consistently overestimate the blue
and underestimate the red
temperature also warps time the hotter
we are the faster we feel at passing
the music too oddly up tempo music
decelerates time and down tempo music
hastens it
so if smooth jazz heat waves and a bit
of blue are enough to mangle time
no wonder pandemic up ended it
in 1983 a paper published in the journal
science
described an experiment in which
researchers claimed to have overridden
the human eyes
opponency mechanism allowing people to
see impossible colors
the participants said the colors were
vivid and awe-inducing
but entirely indescribable like seeing
red for the first time
and having no name for it i imagine them
returning to their lives
tucking the impossible colors away into
the closets where we store
our most inarticulable memories but had
they not been alone in what they'd
witnessed
if the whole world had woken up one day
suddenly able to see a new color
i think we would have created a name in
a matter of hours
because when it comes to color we
innately gravitate towards classifying
what we see
naming the shade between orange and red
pink calling the blue of the aegean
royal and the blue of the caribbean
aquamarine
but when it comes to time we have such a
limited lexicon fast
slow long short future present past
beyond that we're pretty much speechless
but not hopeless
in 1812 dietrich nicholas finkel
invented the metronome
but 200 plus years later classical
composers still prefer to communicate
musical time
in sentimental italian
tempo cheerful time
[Music]
cheerful time but not too much
[Music]
stolen time maybe we've been too fixated
on
fixing our metronomes when what we need
most is vocabulary for these new colors
of time
to describe 17 second months millennium
long days and a year without any parties
language for when time undergoes a phase
transition right there in your hand
days melting and months evaporating and
years freezing
maybe there's a word for that in italian
maybe it translates to impossible time
just to see